another element that might have catched
your attention is something that is
called a sticker and this is what you
see here in the top right so sticker is
a qualification of a page that you use
here you see the preliminary sticker and
stickers are elements that are pretty
much used to protect yourself so why
could this be important why would you
need to protect yourself so let's
imagine you make an analysis which might
be a bit controversial you know that the
results will not please everybody then
what you can do is to include such a for
discussion sticker so then if you walk
into a meeting and then you realize that
your analysis sparked some discussion
then in the end you can say well yes of
course this is not the final result this
is just for discussion as we also wrote
here